ISS of whether or not I could have
Assurance of Salvation And if I have it
what it even feels like well Assurance
be honest yes go ahead go ahead be
honest no just because to be honest with
you Sam you know especially if we're
struggling with sins and stuff like that
a lot of times it it it it hinders my
ability to have the joy and the Peace of
knowing that I'm saved yes this is an
emotional struggle that Satan
capitalizes on so let me your your issue
is not so much scriptural as it is
psychological and emotional because
Satan is playing with your weakness so
I'm glad you ask me the question yes the
Assurance of Salvation is this if you're
acknowledging your sin and you're
acknowledging your struggle and you
don't justify it even though you succumb
to it and you don't want to but you do
and you're not justifying it you're
saying it's sin and I hatte it and
you're crying out to the Lord Jesus is a
god of infinite mercy and love he's more
merciful than you can IM imagine if
you're clinging to him and you don't let
go he will preserve you and forgive you
and transform
you the issue is what does it mean say
it
again what does it mean to cling to him
cling to him meaning you are
acknowledging what he says about your
situation in other words if you're
struggling with homosexuality let's say
I'm not saying you are my cousin
saycheese he's you know there you know
the jury's out on him he's like kind of
the way he laughs and he looks I'm
wondering if he struggles with
homosexual proclivities but that's my
cousin I'll have a private session with
him but you sound masculine but let's
say you're struggling with homosexual
desires
okay you're admitting it's wrong you're
admitting it's sin you're admitting it's
evil you acknowledge what Jesus says and
you are resisting it that's clinging to
Christ saying Lord I agree with you this
is wrong I don't want to do it help me
and God shows you
Mercy you understand that's why even
David was called the man after God's
heart let me explain why David was
called a man after God's heart if you go
to acts 13 and you read from 22 onwards
why was David the man after God's heart
when he was a murderer and he was an
adulterer and a womanizer not because
God loved the sin because David
acknowledged his sinfulness didn't
justify it didn't double down when he
was confronted with sin he broke before
God and admitted I am a sinner and I
deserve to die
because of that humble attitude God
forgave
him what God hates is people who cover
their sin by trying to justify it excuse
it and say it's okay so that they can
continue living that way that's not you
from your Agony you're showing God you
love him so much it's hurting you and
killing you that you can't overcome this
specific sin and you're ashamed and
you're fearing that God will reject you
no that that's the kind of heart that
God loves someone who acknowledges I'm
broken I'm sinful I'm struggling I know
it's sin I know you hate it I don't want
to do it I'm weak God has nothing but
love and mercy if you acknowledge
it how do I how do I know that it's in
God's uh nature to not give up on me how
do I know that I ever reached a point
where God just says enough with this guy
he's sinned times I've gave him too many
chances
easy if God had handed you over one sign
you could you would care less about God
you wouldn't care what the Bible says
you wouldn't care what Jesus has to say
and you wouldn't care about the Bible
you would hate the Bible and Jesus and
rebel and now fight Jesus and his words
like many atheists do that's how you
know he hasn't given up on you one sign
that God gives up on you because he's
tired with you is he hands you over to
your desires that's Romans 1 I'm going
to give you the verses and you guys can
go read them later Romans 1
24 right Romans 1 24-32 okay it says
when a person has reached a level of
depravity and continues to willfully
indulge in that depravity and justifies
it God hands you over then your
conscience becomes so seared you could
care less anymore and that's also 2
Thessalonians chapter 2 vers 9-2 2
Thessalonians 29-12 that's how you know
God has hand you over when you you don't
care about God don't care about calling
it sin you actually Relish in it you
love it you justify it and now you
attack God and his Bible and try to
destroy the faith of Christians that's
how you know you've reached that
point and another way I know that God
hasn't given up on you because Jesus
told Simon Peter are you ready for
this yes in Matthew 18 21-35 you got to
read the entirety because Jesus gives a
parable matth 18
21-35 Peter says to Jesus Lord how many
times should I sin I mean how many times
should I forgive my brother right if he
sins against me seven times Jesus says I
tell you 70 times seven forgive him 490
times a day if he acknowledges he's
sinning and he turns to you now if Jesus
is telling me to open the door to
forgive my brother who sins against me
and acknowledges he sin against me and
he regrets it and never Clos the door
how much more Jesus whose heart whose
love is infinitely more than mine how
much more will the door of forgiveness
be open for you when it comes to
Jesus so God is is
it go
ahead I I wonder for the people who do
fall away is it is it a decision that
they make or is it God Mak
pulling away from them no it's a
decision you make you turn from God
because you don't trust God and take it
at his word so then God honors your
decision and hands you over and I'll
prove it to you again I'm going to give
you scripture in John 6 if you read from
60 to 66 there were a group of disciples
that were following Jesus John 6
60-66 when Jesus says You Must Eat My
Flesh and drink my blood they started
complaining this is a hard saying who
can accept it then Jesus exposed why
they were complaining cuz he knew that
they didn't really believe from their
heart it says in John 664 he knew they
didn't really really believe from their
heart so he knew because their faith
wasn't genuine they're going to fall
away and then that's why he says in John
665 for this reason I said no one can
come to me unless the father draws him
and then 66 says at this they left him
never to walk with him again and Jesus
allowed them to leave he didn't throw
them out they left and he honored their
decision
you see got it yes but one thing I want
to tell you how San what Satan does when
you say how do I feel it the Bible says
you got to reach a point in your life
that you can't base it on your feelings
you have to base it on God's word and
his character let me explain what I mean
Proverbs 28:26
says a fool trusts in his own heart in
your own thinking your own feelings
your feelings are corrupted tainted
because of your sinful desires because
of your upbringing because of society
and Satan your emotions will mislead you
and Satan knows that so Satan will play
on your emotions to make you feel so
guilty so dirty unworthy that you're
ashamed to face God and turn away
because you're too embarrassed because
you don't think you're good enough and
then by keeping you away then what
happens is the more you keep yourself
away from God the more you die to God
the more you don't care and then you
reach a point you give up are you with
me
there yes okay now this is Satan playing
on your mind but this is why Jesus is
telling you you can't go by how you feel
you have to take me by my word trust me
I am the way the truth in life I cannot
lie so if I tell you if you are broken
over your sin and you acknowledge it sin
and you don't want to sin because you
love me and you hate when you sin
against me even though you fall you
acknowledge it trust me I won't give up
on you I'll forgive you but Satan plays
on your mind to make you feel too
guilty right too guilty so that you now
start doubting Jesus and trusting your
emotions which is what Satan wants to
do so Jesus is telling you will you take
me at my word
and trust
me that when I tell you this is who I am
and the door of forgiveness will always
be open if you acknowledge you're
sinning and you're broken before me
because I will never leave nor forsake
you I'll never abandon you because I
love you more than you know and if you
confess like 1 John 1 7 to10 says I will
forgive you will you believe me or are
you going to trust your emotions that
are being manipulate by Satan to
distrust me because that's what he wants
to make you feel so guilty you no longer
trust in the Lord so he can destroy
you so what are you going to do are you
going to trust Jesus or your
emotions I'm gonna trust Jesus so stop
going by your emotions this is why
marriages fail now let me tie it in with
marriage because Jesus says he's our
husband we're his bride right right do
you know why marriages fail one big
reason because people emotionally check
out those butterflies in the stomach
they had when they first dated it's gone
so because they don't get any emotional
stimulus from their partner then they
think their relationship is not worth
pursuing so they leave for someone else
that causes them to have butterflies in
their stomach and this is why they go
from one marriage to another or one
relationship to another because they
haven't learned that love is not just
emotion it's a commitment to do what is
right in the side of God and do what is
beneficial for the other in other words
love is action not just feeling
and if you don't train yourself to get
to the point that love is not just how I
feel love is something I do to show my
devotion to the person whether I feel
like it or not it's like work there are
days when you get up you don't feel like
working but you still go to work because
you know if you don't work you're going
to lose your job and be homeless right
yes how much more
relationships so Jesus is saying you may
not have those butterflies in your
stomach for me that doesn't matter you
have to go beyond feeling and still
pursue me trust me and do what I tell
you CU I know what's best for you